Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoy the video and yeah, let's begin,
do not be too proud of this technological terror. You've constructed.
The ability to destroy a planet is insignificant next to the power of the force
or of the year 2020, which has been absolute garbage so far.
It's going on guys? This is Rob and, uh, I woke up a little bit ago.
So any of you guys who are familiar with my YouTube channel know that I have
this pretty deep voice when I first wake up, uh,
it will change as we go on through the video. The more that I talk, but we are,
uh, we're covering the secret origin of death metal, right?
This is technically super boy prime versus the Batman who laughs. But, uh,
it's really, really cool, right? It's a really, really amazing story.
So what we, what we really, I wouldn't really even say that we like anything,
what we would normally do. And so far,
it's kind of like doing a bit of a breakdown about Subaru prime before we
actually start the story we don't need to do because it gets covered in the
story. And that really makes a lot of sense.
Given the fact that Superboy prime hasn't shown up in DC comics for quite some
time. And there is a little bit of a refresher that's needed for people who are
getting into the character for the very first time,
because a lot of people know the character by name,
they're aware of Superboy prime, the power he possesses.
He's probably the strongest version of Superman that be seen in any of the
crisis events minus, you know,
the one that adapts to everybody's powers and like a few exceptions here and
there.
But in terms of like the main line Superman who come from Krypton and that kind
of a thing he's usually considered to be the most powerful, uh,
they don't really know the history of the character. And so because of that, uh,
we get a little bit of a, of an explanation here.
One of the things that does get left out is the nature of Krypton in the sense
that this, this basically takes place on earth,
punt and earth prime is essentially DC stand in for the real world, right?
So like our world where you're watching this video and all that kind of good
stuff, but the whole idea behind this is that,
that this guy Clark Kent had basically come from Krypton here in the real world.
The difference is that unlike DC comics and almost any other universe or Krypton
explodes in his universe, Krypton is destroyed by the sun.
And the result of that is that there is no kryptonite from the earth prime
universe, right? Kryptonite comes from a planet, Krypton, shard,
the reader found in space or landed on earth.
And that's how Superman gets his weakness to green kryptonite. Uh,
the reality is that here there is no kryptonite anywhere in the universe.
And so the result is that Superboy prime does not have a weakness to kryptonite
because it doesn't exist. Presumably if it did, he would,
but the other counterpart to this or the other component to this is that
kryptonite from other dimensions,
other universes does not work on Superboy prime.
So he has no inherent immunity to the kryptonite in any form or fashion.
It's one of the things that really bolsters his power. Now in this moment,
he's kind of in a local comic book store, just kind of reading comics and this,
some guys show up on him and start giving them a hard time,
making fun of him because he likes Superman.
What kind of an idiot makes fun of somebody because they like Superman at this
point. Like these guys, right?
This kid Braverman basically ends up ripping up the common book that Clark
Kent's reading.
And then in turn either just go start beating the crap out of them, right?
I don't know why you'd beat somebody up for liking comics, but you know,
this was the 1980s. Things were a little bit different back then,
but then Lori comes out of nowhere,
basically splashes water on them and is like, my mom owns a drug store.
You guys are banned for life. Now, Laurie was the love interest. When,
when Superboy prime originally showed up in DC comics, back in the day,
Lori was his love interest. And by all standards of measurements,
she was essentially his at his lowest lane, right?
She was the counterpart to him by the character that would go on,
they'd have kids and have a life together and all that stuff,
the caveat to this and the,
and the big kicker of all this is that when Subaru crash landed on earth was
ultimately adopted by John. And [inaudible] again,
he never really knew anything about it, about his origin.
And so the funny thing is,
it's not like it's ours came about by way of him just arbitrarily lifting up a
tractor one day or something like that. His powers had to be activated.
And the way this activation came out was that because of his love for Superman,
uh, Laurie got him a Superman outfit to wear to this big costume party they were
going to go to.
And so once they get to this beach where all their friends are dressed up as
superheroes and so on and so forth,
and they're all just kind of hanging out that a comment passes by.
And when this comment passes by,
it emits a kind of radiation that basically activate Superboy primes powers.
And now all the powers of Superman, right?
He's flying all that kind of good stuff,
any kind of reminiscence about this ride.
He reminisces about his life with Laurie when its power is activated, how,
like how much he cared about her, how much they were going to go forward,
probably have a life together.
And then suddenly Superman from the main DC universe popped up and said,
there's an event going on called crisis on infinite earth. We need your help.
And ultimately this led to Subaru prime, basically, you know,
joining the various superheroes off against the anti monitor and in the
aftermath of that Superboy prime locked away in a paradise dimension or went to
a paradise dimension because of the fact that his whole world had been
destroyed. That earth Pont was basically gone. Laurie was gone and the,
the desire to get her back,
the desire for all those things basically came to fruition with him leading to
his current state. Now, if you want to know more about super white climate,
because we don't really have enough time to cover it all,
I'll have the link to infinite crisis down in the description where you can
basically get caught up with all this stuff that takes place in between ween
super boy prime,
going into the paradise dimension at the end of crisis on infinite earth.
And this started this story more or less, right?
There's a few other things here and there with, they're not super important,
but you know,
infinite crisis is the story that everybody references when they talk about
super white prod, right? Less, that's like the must read Superboy prime story.
And so because of that,
all the other heroes who were here after experiencing their battles with
Superboy prime and knowing him as they know him,
a lot of the kind of turns into can we even really trust this guy.
And while he's using a super hearing to kind of listen to what they're saying at
the end of the day, they're just kind of like easy kind of like, all right,
these guys still don't really like me and still don't really trust me.
And for good reason, I mean, this guy broke out of the paradise dimension.
He literally shattered the dimensional barrier,
broke out of the paradise dimension and just went on a warpath in the main DC
universe. There's one point where he fought the doom, patrol the team Titans,
young justice.
And I think justice league all at the same time and like overpowered all of
them, right?
Like he beat them all and was like killing people and all kinds of stuff.
He just become this really twisted and dark character,
which was an amazing story. The way it was done. It was,
it was so well written by Jeff Johns.
But what you end up getting here is in this moment when he's kind of accepted,
coming to grips with the fact that nobody really trusts him,
none of the superheroes on earth, that in reality,
while reading about them through comedy books in own universe, uh,
that he came to to respect and to adore that, you know,
in his loss of respect for him, for all these different guys,
with me within the paradise dimension, to the events that followed after,
they don't see him as a superhero. And so he effectively became the villain,
right?
He became the one thing he never wanted to be when he was going through and
reading comic books as a kid.
And then suddenly he's met by the arrival of crypto and crypto is, is, see,
this is the thing about crypto crypto is amazing, right?
The great thing about Dodge, if you guys don't own dogs,
the great things about dogs is that it really is just unconditional love dogs.
Don't care about, about like your, your political beliefs. They don't care.
They don't care about anything, right?
All dogs care about is that you love them and pet them and that you feed them
and that you take them for walks and let them go have fun.
That's all they care about. And they will love you unconditionally in return.
And that kind of unconditional love from crypto being basically shown to super
by prime is something that he hasn't experienced.
For a long, long, long.
Time. And it kind of allows a little bit of a softer side to it, right.
Where he starts talking about crypto, you know, and it's like, man, I'm when I,
when I first read a story about you will, as he's petting crypto,
suddenly super boy comes running up, right. He come showing up on him,
counter kids, stupid selfie, come showing up on him.
And it just kind of like leave crypto alone. Right. You know, like, like,
you know, if you, if you heard him all bash your brains in, right,
like all destroy. Now,
here's the reason why this has dumped the last time these two guys fought
Connor, Kent got rushed. And not even by a little bit, either,
it wasn't even like a close fight, you know, where it's like,
man counter kit's holding on by a thread guys. Do you think you'll pull it out?
I don't know. See what my prime is. It looked like he has much,
much left either commended enough.
Superboy prime had a full tank and was still hammering on Connor Kent. Right?
I mean, this guy never, he never had a chance.
Anybody who ever said that Connor Ken had a chance against super-prime is lying
to themselves. That's just the way that is. Right.
Super wind farm was just that powerful.
And so the reality of this is that the reason why they're all kind of here in
this moment is because they're waiting on these 52 worlds to arrive that are all
basically filled with different analogs of Superman.
But we saw this at the end of, I think death metal, number four, or death metal,
number five, but they're all basically just waiting on all these different,
these different heroes, or I guess, you know,
twisted versions of themselves to show up so they can face off against them,
destroy them. And then, you know, that's basically it.
And so what you end up having here, this is a cool moment.
What you end up having here is that in this moment,
when Superboy prime faces off against this one, dark analog of Superman,
that assay to feed him and then ultimately kills him that he sees his world and
then feels it change. And then his thought becomes, okay, so like, why, like,
why is this the case, right. If I, if I kill this guy, right? Like if I,
if I kill this guy and take him out, then why does this world change?
Initially the superheroes think he's abandoning them,
but he takes off into space with this kind of realization. And he says,
just outside earth orbit, I see the last 52 worlds all lined up, right?
The world that this bad guy created to destroy everything in everyone,
the bad guy, of course referencing the Batman who laughs. And he says,
and then I wonder, can I use these? Can I change all of them?
If I kill this monster? Now remember did the nature of the dark multi-verse.
And then presumably the worlds of the Batman who laughs created is that they're
dark and twisted versions of essentially existing worlds or concepts.
Remember it, when it comes to the multi-verse and DC comics,
there's only really 52 worlds that are ever established by DC,
but there's an actual infinite number of worlds out there, right.
We just only ever really see 52 of them. And so, because of this,
what we're kind of getting here is this idea that all the Batman who laughs
basically dead,
it's take the idea of worlds that succeeded and then create in turn like dark
multi-verse versions of those, right?
Where the worlds of twisted up and the worlds have been screwed up.
The idea seems to be that there's an anchor point there, right?
There's a Genesis, a point by which that world changed.
And if you basically destroy that,
then what is basically doing is pulling out the wrong Jinga piece at the bottom
of a Jinga set at the wrong time. And the entire thing comes crashing down.
It creates a cascading effect.
And so if that Superman in that alternate reality is dead.
Then the world will shift back to normal, right?
Presumably the Batman who laughs control over that world will be removed.
And it'll, it'll go back to the way that it was supposed to be.
Now we're not told if it's like an automatic thing, right? If like, you know,
this new, new Superman is introduced and then like there's some magic.
This Dawn in the world is twisted up. And then like, as soon as the,
as soon as the Superman's killed,
like the world just snaps back and everybody's like, wow, what happened?
You know, this is kind of crazy. We're not told if it's that way.
Or if it's because of the depth of that dark character,
that the world can actually begin the process of becoming a better place.
We're not really told if it's hard and fast or a little more nuanced in terms of
how it works. We're simply just hold that Batman who laughs. If he's destroyed,
these worlds will seemingly continue to exist,
but they're basically function in a pretty normalized way. Now,
one thing that I do also want to draw your attention to here is that we were
basically told at the end of the last issue with death metal,
if there's only going to be one continuity after all this,
it seemingly going to be a crisis event with like a new earth, right?
One single universe.
There's not going to be a whole bunch of different alternate realities out
there, whether that's true or not. I don't know. But if that's true,
then seemingly these worlds would have to be destroyed or removed somewhere
along the line.
It may just be one of these things where it's kind of like a blend between the
multi-verse and the new earth concept after crisis on infinite earths,
where basically there's a multiverse out there. We just never explore it.
We just never see it. Right.
We only ever focus on this one particular world and that's basically it,
it could be more metaphorical that statement in way, or it could be literal,
right work. Every single world of the multi-verse is destroyed.
And there's only one universe left.
We don't really know what we do know is that we end up seeing superway prime
going directly after the Batman who laughs. And one of the things,
one of the comments we get right off the bat here is that the Batman who laughs
kind of analyzes them and says, okay,
there's more to you than I thought there would be.
You're kind of a funny one here, right? This is a little bit different.
You're kind of a funny one here. This was a little strange.
And so the two of them actually ended up fighting against each other.
Now something that happens here in something that I'm not really entirely sure
about how I feel as that Superbowl prime is able to successfully go toe to toe
with the Batman who lasts somebody to understand the Batman who laughs is a
version of Batman powered by basically Dr. Manhattan's powers.
What this really tells us here is that Superboy prime is equal to Dr. Manhattan
power, if not more powerful.
And the reason why is because as they fight against each other,
as they go to go toe to toe in this kind of bare bare knuckle just knocked down,
drag out Raul that there is some, some taunting,
there is some intimidation going back and forth.
And so far Subaru prime talking trash,
the Batman who laughs talking trash to Superboy prime and super-prime is
literally getting the upper hand and absolutely pummeling the sky and the Batman
who laughs does what he can. Right. And basically says like,
I can give you the world that you want the world war Lori's back where
everything you could possibly want would come true.
But silverware prime rejects it because at the end of the day,
the big difference between Superbowl prime and the Batman who laughs is that
prime wanted to do the right thing, right?
He wanted to get the heroes back to being traditional good guys.
It just happened to be, he went about it in all the wrong ways.
The Batman who laughs just wants to make everything evil, right?
He doesn't have any good intentions that he's implementing in the wrong way.
The way Superboy prime did. He just wants to, he just wants to cause chaos,
death instruction and just make everything really crappy. Right? And so,
because of that, where you end up having super prime, just humbling.
The Batman who laughs then suddenly out of nowhere,
when he goes in for the killing blow, crypto shows up and cry and he's kind of,
he kind of tells crypto like go right. You can't stay here.
And so that's when things get kind of bonkers is because the Batman who laughs
makes this comment a super-wide from you can't destroy me any more than I can
destroy you. So let me help you. And again,
that's where he basically offers him this opportunity again. And,
and really like even,
even Batman who laughs shows him what this world could look like, right?
That he could see this world where he is a member of the justice league.
He fights alongside the other superheroes. He celebrated and accepted as a hero.
The world sees him as everything that he always wanted to be when he was reading
the stories about becoming Superman. But at the end of the day,
he closes his hand and he says, no, I can't accept that. Right?
Because it's a world without his parents.
It's a world without Laurie is a world without everything he ever wanted.
And that's all he ever did want. That's that's the,
that's the important thing to understand about Superboy product. When you,
when you reduce him down past all the infinite crisis, past pummeling,
the earth superheroes being stuck in the source wall,
being locked away by the green lanterns and science cells.
When you remove all that stuff, right?
All that talk and all that jargon and you reduce them down to his most base
instinct,
the entire motivation for everything Superboy prime has ever done in the
history of DC comics is to get back to his home with his parents and Laurie.
And that is what made Superboy prime,
such an incredible and relatable character.
That's what made him so awesome is because who of us has not been thrust in a
situation where we seemingly lose everything we care about, right?
Sometimes you don't realize what you've lost until it's gone.
Sometimes you realize what you're giving up as you do it.
But regardless of the situation you meet,
everybody in this world is struggling with something. And in some way,
over the course of our life, we've had to give something up. We didn't want to,
but we had to,
and Superboy prime represents that primal desire in all of us to go back to the
way things were right to go back to that point in our life.
When things were at its high point. When,
when we seemingly had everything we could possibly want, that's a strong urge.
That's a strong feeling. And in his desire to get back there,
Superboy prime acted on that and seemingly got lost in his own cost, right?
He ended up becoming everything that he hated,
but the one thing he never wanted to be, that's the thing that he became,
what he sees here.
This is seemingly the perfect life without the one thing that he wants the most,
right? The one thing he wants the most, his parents in Laurie.
And as long as he doesn't have those, it's not a ward worth living it.
And so because of that, he literally balls up and says, okay, one last hot,
right? One last hunt. And he basically lets all of his dreams go right?
His dreams of being with Lori,
his dreams of being back with his mom and his dad, right?
Everything has been holding on to over the course of his life.
He lets all of it go. Now here's the reality of this.
He never would have been able to pull this off. Had he not done that? Right?
Had he not let himself go in that way?
The reality is sometimes you just have to let things go right?
And just move on as tough as it may be. And as hard as it may be,
sometimes that's just what you have to do. And that's what he does. Right?
He takes everything he ever wanted all the life. You wanted to go back to,
he balls it up and he just lets it go.
And just bam punches into the Batman who laughs and shatters him now by all
standards of definition, all standards of measurement,
Superboy prime has seemingly destroyed the Batman who laughs.
And it's kind of weird.
It's a little strange to believe the death of the Batman who laughs doesn't
happen in the main story. It happens in a tie-in.
It's a little strange to believe that if I'm being honest,
I don't really think it's true. And here's the reason why,
what you end up getting here is super boy prime who basically just kind of crash
lands, right? That all these worlds, well everything's more or less destroyed.
Right? But everything seems to kind of crack these worlds.
Look like they're breaking apart. They literally look like they're,
they're starting to kind of shake and just explode.
They're basically coming to an end. And when that happens,
superway prime comes crashing down onto the earth. But no one knows it.
He gets there, right? No one knows it. He arrives there.
They don't even know that he was there facing off against the Batman who laughs.
They don't know about that. Crypto responds to prime and then basically howls.
And the pace of the fact that Subaru prime is dead.
And then suddenly he wakes up in his room. He just wakes up in his room,
reading a comic about his own death. Right.
He's reading this secret origin comic. I know it's a little meta,
but that's what used to happen back in the day.
Like back in the day with earth prime,
they were basically reading comics here in the real-world.
So what you can do in order to make this easier on yourself,
assume that that we're reading a story about a kid who's like five blocks away.
That's what, that's the easiest way to make this make sense, you know,
to kind of make it a little more tangible, but then Lori walks in, right.
And for super bowl prime kind of looking around,
like he remembers everything up to that point.
And then it's like waking up from a dream.
He just snaps up in this place and he's like, this doesn't make any sense.
Like how are you here? Right. And how is like this dog? Like how's crypto here,
like how's is this white dog here? How has any of this stuff here?
This doesn't make any sense to me. Right? It shouldn't be this way.
Like this is a little strange.
And his initial thought is that it's somehow a dream or that none of it's true.
And like, as he's walking with Laurie, he starts talking.
I do remember that Tommy were on the beach and on the comment pass by.
And then I got my powers and I flew up into the sky. Yeah. I mean, I,
that's a great story. It's a, you know, it's a cool story that you love telling,
but like, you know your car can't without powers and that's okay. Right.
You're not Superman. Right.
And so what ends up happening is as this car is driving down the road,
this kid goes running out into the street to chase a bouncing ball,
which is a pretty stupid, typical situation, right?
Kids just run into the streets, chasing balls.
And so Superboy prime or at least cargo's running out there to,
to save this kid and ends up picking up the car right now.
If I'm being honest with you guys, I think this is all an illusion.
I think it's all fake. I think that it's basically the Batman who laughs,
who has this much power, power enough to create worlds.
I have a hard time believing he'd be toppled that quickly by Superboy prompt.
I think that what he's done is he's tricked Superboy five into believing that
he's dead. And then in turn,
he's basically just kind of conjured this world out of nowhere and then said
like, this is the world you could have. If you leave me be right.
That's basically it either that, or he's just going to torment. And again,
who knows, but with that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain mission.
You guys at the sub button to become part of the rod pork.
If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a light.
Now we'll catch you all later. Peace.
[Inaudible].